c'est sans doute un moment singulier qui
nous réunit si l'on considère le
calendrier mais le sujet majeur n'est
pas là et je voudrais citer simone veil
au fond tout au long de ma vie dit elle
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir ouvrir des
brèches dans le conformisme ambiant
ces quelques mots de simone veil résonne
tout particulièrement
simone veil l'européenne partisane du
rapprochement franco allemand
simone veil l'a réformatrice qui a su
tisser des liens entre des bords
politiques souvent artificiellement
opposé simone veil qui a traduit
l'aspiration de la société française à
évoluer avec son temps
quitte à dépasser le conformisme ambiant
ensemble nous portons je crois la même
aspiration à ouvrir sereinement le débat
sur l'avenir du pays
oui de simone veil je retiendrai d'abord
l'ardente obligation de dépasser les
conformismes je pense parmi ceux-ci à la
coupure artificielle entre les français
ces deux camps qui s'affrontent et c'est
release le débat le centre a toujours
porter ce message la nécessité celle
d'un système politique à bout de souffle
nous conduit à revisiter ce vieux
clivages l'impérieux besoin de réformer
le pays nous y invite
la situation de nos finances publiques
nous y contrat et nous devons d'abord
faire face au terrorisme
assurer ensemble la sécurité nos
compatriotes éradiquer les terroristes
répondre à ce défi à notre mode de vie à
nos valeurs à notre conception la
liberté face aux terroristes nous devons
bien sûr être unis nous devons aussi
faire face aux défis territoriales
évitez les territoires de relégation du
moins ceux perçus comme tels chacun
mesure qu'il erre dans le monde rural
comme en banlieue du désespoir et des
français au terme d'une campagne certes
inédite nous ont placés devant cette
évidence
comme le disait valéry giscard d'estaing
pour réformer il faut rassembler deux
français sur trois nous sommes sans
équivoque à un moment clé après tant de
tergiversations
ce quinquennat doit réussir ce doit être
enfin un quinquennat utile nous devons
franchir ensemble ce pas décisif que nos
voisins européens
ont su franchir bâtir un socle de
réforme
ensuite nous verrons si les vieux
clivages reviennent il ya aujourd'hui
une urgence qui nous rappelle celle
qu'invoquer en son temps pierre
mendès-france celle de gouverner donc de
choisir
il ya une réalité financière qui
illustre la vérité les analyses de
raymond barre sur l'évolution de la
dépense publique
il ya un besoin aussi d'ingénierie
sociale qui nous invite à reprendre des
analyses de michel rocard
il ya surtout un besoin de restaurer la
grandeur de la france
il doit nous conduire à garder toujours
dans nos têtes le message de
rassemblement du général de gaulle alors
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
là dans cette configuration inédite
novatrice et le groupe union centriste
du sénat est heureux que vous soyez là
notre ancien collègue jacqueline
gourault appartient à votre gouvernement
le groupe qui au sénat réunie depuis des
années des sénateurs de l'udps et y ait
du modèle soutiendra largement l'action
de réforme du gouvernement
nous aurons sans doute au sénat à
trouver dans les semaines qui viennent
et même au delà des majorités d'idées
évidemment nous aurons des sujets de
débats à la place des collectivités
locales leur autonomie financière
notamment au regard du projet
d'exonération de la taxe d'habitation
des questions sociétales la vision vous
pouvez avoir de ces sujets appellerons
sans doute des interrogations nous
serons surtout exigeant exigeants sur la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques la
réduction de la dette
exigeons sur la défense du
parlementarisme et la démocratie locale
qui ne doivent pas être mise en cause
comme une facilité offerte à l'opinion
quand bien même nous devons nous le
savons améliorer l'efficacité de nos
travaux exigent sur les conditions d'un
débat politique ouvert pleinement
ouverts au parlement exigeant sur la
démocratie sociale le dialogue social
qu'il faut rénover mais qui doivent être
les moteurs de la transformation de
notre économie et de sa compétitivité
nous aurons force de proposition bien
sûr sur l'europe l'enjeu est d'abord de
retrouver auprès de nos partenaires
une capacité à promouvoir les réformes
de la zone euro intégration plus poussée
budget commun la priorité est aussi à
une europe qui protège à ce titre la
prise de conscience de la nécessité pour
les européens d'assurer eux-mêmes leur
défense est une bonne chose
nous voulons inscrire la france dans une
europe puissante une europe qui nous
protège de la mondialisation une europe
qui renforce notre souveraineté et qui
contribue à ce que la france rayonne
dans le monde à la hauteur de son
message concernant les relations
internationales qui le président
république a abordé
plus que jamais il nous faut conforter
nos alliances historiques et nouer des
partenariats stratégiques
pas seulement pour des raisons
économiques aussi parce que notre
sécurité intérieure se joue à
l'extérieur pour vaincre la stratégie de
la terreur des extrémistes religieux des
voiliers pour lutter à long terme contre
le terrorisme la politique nous mènerons
à l'extérieur de nos frontières au
moyen-orient au proche orient sera
également déterminante
nous serons bien sûr également vigilant
s'agissant du climat les engagements
pris à la coop 21 doit être respectée et
la france a une responsabilité
particulière à la suite de jean louis
borloo nous pensons qu'elle doit être
pleinement exemplaires et novatrice la
transformation écologique est un élément
de la solution de nos difficultés
au delà la modernisation de notre
économie est nécessaire celle du marché
du travail est un préalable
cette nécessité pour l'emploi nous
pouvons rester parmi les rares pays
avait à voir un tel niveau de chômage
nous devons tirer les conséquences de la
mondialisation mesurer avec lucidité les
mutations technologiques
il faut s'en saisir ne pas les subir il
ya dans notre beau pays une aspiration
de liberté dans l'économie dans les
parcours de vie et une attente de
protection nouvelle face à ces
changements il y a deux préalables la
réussite le rétablissement de la
confiance dans l'action publique
le retour à une maîtrise des finances
publiques c'est sur ces deux points
toujours des cons en matière
institutionnelle le président de
république a annoncé tout à l'heure en
somme de propositions nous les
regarderons avec beaucoup d'intérêt
notre groupe a toujours défendu
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle dans le système
représentatif
aujourd'hui nous pouvons que saluer le
cap pris par l'exécutif
notre groupe participera autant que
possible à l'identification et du
nécessaire
éternel compromis entre gouvernabilité
et représentativité de man sont
favorables à la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
mais là encore la question du nombre ne
doit pas être l'arbre qui cache la forêt
concernant enfin la maîtrise de nos
dépenses et de la dette
les la reconnaissance par la cour des
comptes que le projet de loi de finances
pour 2010 est soumis à la représentation
nationale était manifestement entaché
d'un sa vérité sonne comme un ultime
rappel à l'ordre
le vrai risque est maintenant celui des
marchés financiers il est latent nous
devons nous fixer l'objectif de sortir
de la procédure européenne de déficit
excessif
le parlement prendra toute sa place dans
l'effort de redressement du pays un
parlement qui mesure à sa juste valeur
latente de l'opinion et qui dans le cas
de la séparation des pouvoirs poursuivra
sa rénovation comme le sénat pour ce qui
le concerne la ddt est déjà largement
engagé autour de son président nous
serons ouverts aux propositions du
gouvernement
il s'agit pour une fois de faire mentir
raymond aron qui disait la france fait
de temps en temps une révolution mais
ahmed réforme
aujourd'hui la vraie révolution est de
réussir les réformes
merci